you can see something is mandatory yes
madam if you go ygv you know this all I
do the line coats akela I like my dream
straight
something that I can't go around another
essential item for me is this your nail
right here you know what I'm saying
Chanel blue I love it I hope that makes
you never eat but it's it in I'm rocking
with this when I was the kid racing
where I actually y'all in the locker
room was [ __ ] for my accidents of
practice and all that we grown me got a
smell right no I'm saying you gotta
track people
you got a smell right you got to look
like a snack you smell like a snack
[Music]
he's another one of my senses I've seen
easiest mandatory and wise he step
outside I gotta had a local song and
they come in all different colors
I caught him Lopes these ain't likes to
[ __ ] the easy used to wear all that type
of [ __ ] you know I'm sayin G [ __ ] this
is my G [ __ ] yeah I'm saying cuz I'm
mixing the G [ __ ] with the fashion [ __ ]
the world is full of fake [ __ ]
and I don't like looking fake
[ __ ] in their eyes you know
what I'm saying
so I put the local song and they protect
me and save me from all the fake
[ __ ] in this world this
Bluetooth speakers there's another one
of my essentials this is mandatory when
I when I hit the road and I'm traveling
I gotta had this I pull up in the 5-star
Hotel I turned his [ __ ] and hooked
the [ __ ] up to my phone and I slapped
[ __ ] loud as [ __ ] I make music I'm into
music I gotta keep myself around music
I'm saying and he got to be loud I'm
listening to strangers my before my
music come out I make sure I listen to
every track in different environments
like all different type of speakers the
car speakers the Bluetooth speakers the
iPhones two laptops in the club you know
what I'm saying
like the mixes you got to make sure they
take bang on
this is another one of my senses you
know I'm saying my favorite color is red
so this is just a representation of my
favorite color you know nothing to see I
like the weird on my next worried about
you know why G so because it's like
people want to feel like I'm saying they
connect with you so people feel like
they know your favorite color and your
birthday and all that type of [ __ ] in
your government name then you're gonna
get flex this right here you gotta have
one of these and these come in handy for
all different type of occasions use and
we're not gonna get into them I use this
for utility purposes and cut wires I
thought I use this folk and that's it
mine existential water my got in my
pocket take it everywhere with me I
can't go anywhere without the hardcopy
though they sink that soft board it's
that hard time I love paying with cash
money but fine got enough cash money on
me
it's American Express get the job done
hey this next joint so essentially I
gotta take it off my feet right now if
you know why gee you know why he got in
the heart bottoms
these is Christian Dior's though there's
a shining Michael Jackson swag I'm
saying I'm inspired by told us about our
old game since the og gangsters eighties
and [ __ ]
the word to try to put me in the box but
[ __ ] that I'm more than that and when I
pull up you gonna look at me you won't
see that you know that this is one of my
almost everyday essentials mandatory so
this next essential is very important
where like every day mrs. gold Rolex
ring it's the custom world it ain't made
by brothers but I got to got the rollers
links where I wear these rings because
it's good when you get in the situation
and you gotta get about that situation
I'm left-handed so my left hand strong
so when I can come is coming and then my
right hand
what everything like my left so I wear
this Rolex ring on my right so when this
comes you can feel it you know what I
say the final and most essential to me
is the hummus can't go nowhere without
the ponies whoa
[Music]